this is
state versus barristone indictment
1912-09-i we're continuing with the
trial
we may have appearances
good morning arms you're honored through
the court christopher sheldon crystal
the record will reflect mr barrisson as
president court
justin proper trial attire
all right we're ready to proceed with
your witness we are judge can i just put
one thing on the record sure uh for this
morning um i anticipate calling vanessa
medrano cortez today who is the dcp p
worker your honor had signed a
protective order on january 31st 2020
releasing certain dcp records to the
parties
and in that order it indicates on page
two no party or counsel for any party
shall make reference to the substance of
it within dcp records in the public
domain without prior
leave of the court
judge we did mark those i believe it's
15 pages as s174
i don't intend to introduce that as an
exhibit but i may refer to it with the
witness if she needed a direct
recollection refreshed or something in
that picture all right very good thank
you all right let's call the jurors
oh
so
please come in here
let's try the entry
good morning everyone please be seated
we're going to continue with the trial
in state versus barosome
we're going to continue with the direct
examination of dr ruth cox
want to call in your witness yes john if
we could call dr ruth cox
morning doctor well good morning to you
how are you very well thank you um we
need to re-swear you since we broke
during the day so left hand on the bible
raise your right hand my clerk will
administer the oath do you swear in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony gives to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth enough about the truth
yes ma'am please state your name and
spell your last name for the record ruth
pinix cox last name c c-o-x
thank you doctor have a seat thank you
please continue mr shellhorn
thank you your honor good morning dr cox
good morning
i think we left off yesterday
just before i was going to ask you some
questions about august 7th but i did
just want to follow up on two things we
discussed yesterday the first is uh
with respect to the gun s 177 in
evidence
and if you remember yesterday
it was turned the other way
i asked you to show the jury where the
magazine release button was and you
couldn't see it because the
gun was turned around so if you could
just stand up and just point out to the
jury where that button is
is black
so it's that button that's right next to
where the trigger guard is okay
thank you that's it it was just turned
around yesterday i understand yes sir
judge i'd also like permission
to move s-401 into evidence it's a photo
and publish it to the journal
mr bolenkas have you seen s401
401 will be admitted into evidence
doctor we talked yesterday about the
night that michael barrasson asked you
for the gun do you remember that yes sir
i did and i think you had told the jury
that you were
near or around the state the stall where
didi was yes sir i'm showing you what's
uh been marked as s401
do you recognize what s 401 is a picture
of yes sir i did can you tell the jury
what that's a picture yes
this is the stall
that i was spending the night set
michael had concern about
my horse's safety and he had asked me to
spend the nights there in front of his
stall
so that's the stall where dd was was
house
what are those uh areas just
to the left of the stall those are two
wash stalls
and is that horse that we see in the
picture dd
i can't tell you whether that that's him
or not unless you could show me his face
i can't tell you it's kind of the right
color
but it looks like a horse that's been
clipped but i couldn't there were many
many horses there
all right doctor i want to draw your
attention to uh august 7th now wednesday
august 7th do you remember what you were
doing that morning
uh yes sir the long table that's there
uh in the club room i was at the end of
that table that is closest to the front
of the building there were two windows
there with my laptop doing uh work
and at some point do you remember if you
were told or you became aware that there
was someone from child protection at the
farm
yes sir do you remember approximately
what time of day that was
um my best guess would be sometime mid
midday noon times
noon to one
something like that i could not give you
an exact time
you were you were engrossed in your work
yes sir
do you remember if that caseworker was a
man or a woman there was a woman
do you recall how you became aware that
that caseworker was at the farm yes sir
i do
uh mary haskins asked me came over and
asked me if i would be willing to talk
to her she had some questions uh about
michael and the children and she asked
me if i would come and answer her
questions and i agreed to do that and do
you recall where you spoke with the
caseworker yes sir can you tell the jury
yes sir
so
uh
in the pictures uh
if you i'm assuming they've seen
pictures of the club room yes okay so
where the pool table was there's a door
to the left of that pool table that is a
core door between the club room into
michael's work garage where he had his
cars and there's doors on either side of
that so we went because there were
people milling around so we went into
that area and we went to the father's
corner that you could go in that area
and we stood there and talked
besides you and the caseworker was
anyone else present mary haskins was
there
were the doors open or closed they were
closed
now do you know where the defendant was
at the time you went to speak with the
caseworker no no sir i do not
did you see at any point if or when he
left the area of the barn
i can tell you that because of where i
was sitting
at the end of that table
uh with the window there i saw his truck
he had two silver trucks i saw his truck
go down the driveway down the hill
toward the house
i assumed it was him driving
driving that way what's it hold on
doctor
what's the basis
you didn't see who was driving that
truck no sir i did not
was that before or after you went into
the hallway with the caseworker
oh oh that would be after
so after you were talking to the
caseworker you went back to the
table and that's when you saw the truck
yes sir
did you see uh the defendant
running around the the clubhouse or the
stable that afternoon
i saw him around around the area yes
was he yelling or screaming or carrying
on any of that anything of that nature
no sir
now at some point uh that afternoon on
august 7th did you become aware that
police were at the property yes sir
and without getting into specifics of
what someone may or may not have told
you how did you generally become aware
of that
uh
mary haskins father was there
and he i've got some information from
him that
concerned me that something had happened
down at the house and what did you do as
a result of that i got in my truck and
drove down there
uh how when you say down there you mean
to the house to the house uh could you
see the house from when you got into
your truck at the parking lot and
started to drive yes sir i could you
could see the house from the parking lot
what you said once i got in my truck and
started to drive down the hill yes sir
okay so after you got to the top of the
hill you started to drive you could see
the house yes i could
how close did you get to the area of the
house not very close because there were
many many police cars down there there
were many many policemen
and
i got
uh probably
thinking about yards i probably got
15 yards
so if the house is here
the driveway's here i probably got about
15 yards up the driveway and was stopped
am i being clear with that answering
your question i think so so you didn't
get all the way to the driveway no sir
into the back oh no sir there's no way
you could have gotten in there
did you see uh michael barisson in the
area yes i did and you recall oh can you
describe how he
uh whether he was standing sitting
kneeling or something else
uh at one point
he was
kneeling there was a policeman
standing behind him
his his arms were
behind him like that
and then at another time he was sitting
next to the wheels
of
i don't know if it was a trailer or a
car that was there in the parking lot
no i think you said yesterday that at
some time after the police got to the
scene and after the investigation began
that you
were advised or you learned that your
firearm had been recovered by the police
yes
were you asked that night on august 7th
2019 about your file yes sir and were
you shown a picture of a black and pink
nine millimeter ruger by a detective yes
sir
what did you think when the
police officer showed you that picture
my heart sank
i didn't hardly think anything my heart
sank
and had you seen that gun again since
you gave it to michael barisson in this
in the stable a couple of nights earlier
i had not seen that gun again until you
showed it to me in the courtroom did i
understand your question correct i think
so
do you still have any ongoing business
with either mary haskins greg
no i do not how about do you have any
ongoing business with the defendant no
sir i do not
george i don't have any further
questions thank you
what cross-examination
miss cox
you were charged with a criminal offense
correct
yes sir
and
you agreed to
testify
as part of your plea agreement correct
yes sir
the prosecutor just asked you questions
concerning
you
being shown a picture of your gun on the
night
of the incident correct yes sir
and and that's the uh question where you
said your heart stopped correct yes sir
now
you told the police at that time that
you weren't sure if it was you were done
correct yes sir
but deep down in your heart you knew it
was your gun correct
i strongly thought it was my gun yes sir
was there any doubt in your mind
that the gun that they were showing you
at that time
was your gun
well there was a little bit of hope that
it wasn't my gun
until i knew that it was the same serial
number as my gun
now
you've been coming to the farm for
approximately five years correct yes sir
you're coming up this last time that was
what friday before the wednesday
incident yes
sir um
is it an effect that you were asked to
come up
uh by michael barrison
no sir that's not correct who asked you
to come on
i was not directly asked to come up
i had some exchanges
with mh mary haskins
and she told me what was going on up
there
and i had i had had plans to come a week
or so later
and as she and i talked about it we
decided that perhaps it was best that i
come on up that weekend
you basically came up
out of the goodness of your heart to
help them correct that is absolutely
correct sir
and that is after
you were told by mary haskins exactly
what
uh was going on at least according to
her correct yes sir
um
and you were told
can i assume some pretty horrible things
yes sir
now
you were there for
what four or five days before the
incident
yes sir
and and
would you agree with me that
the entire
the entire
situation
was toxic
yes sir
were you there
and did you personally see the police
come
numerous times to the property
yes sir i did
and were you
present
um during any of those times yes sir was
and at any point during those times did
did you hear michael barrisson tell the
police that he was objection
mr
blancas sustained
no
not again
it's the same ruling i had before
it's hearsay
yes it
is all right so you were present when
the police arrived yes sir
and and you saw
the police talking
to michael barrasso correct yes sir
um
were you present when
mary haskins sent her
child away
yes sir was
and was that emotional for her yes sir
do you know when that occurred ma'am
what day after you arrived you said you
arrived on a friday i haven't the
faintest idea
i'm sorry all right but it was during
the time from
the
when i got there on friday uh probably
over that weekend because i had intended
just to come for the weekend
and because things continued to get
worse and worse and more tense and
michael asked me to stay
and so i stayed
but in this is a young child
who
did not need to be in that environment
and that situation at all
and so mh made arrangements
uh for him to leave and to go to her
mother very good thank you
now
were you present when the town officials
came to the property
and
kicked everyone out of
the stable area yes sir was
and from that point on was
michael barissone sleeping outside
on the porch on the mattress
yes sir
now was there
ever a time while you were there
where you were with michael barristone
and
you saw lauren cataract
at night
in the woods
flashing a flashlight on and off
i was there when michael and i were on
the front porch and somewhat saw someone
out in the field
with a flashlight
putting it on and off and on and off
whether it was her or not
i cannot tell you
did you ever
see
lauren cataract and rob goodwin come to
this stable area
and
after hours
and turn all the lights on and start
playing the music loudly
yes sir absolutely did that was why i
was asked by michael
to
uh spend the nights in front of our
horse don devone we called him
affectionately d.d because she would
cunt she and he would come at odd hours
during the night and do exactly as you
said turn all the lights on in the
stable turn on the music
which
in for the horses they should have quiet
and peace at night and not be disturbed
because they are very busy during the
day
and um
that was that was the routine that was
asked to be done at the stables is after
eight o'clock that there be nobody up
there in the stables and and is it safe
to say based on your observations that
lauren cataract
refused to abide by those rules
absolutely sir she did
now
let's talk about this course dede
um
you indicated that michael was concerned
for the safety of that horse on direct
correct yes sir
were you also concerned yes sir i was
concerned as well
how much is dd worth
approximately
um are you asking me how much he was
worth then or how much he might be worth
now
i would assume that
what now
then then yes not now just then at the
time
i would have said he was worth 200
excuse me i would have said i would have
said he was worth probably around 200
000
with the potential to be worth a lot
more correct yes sir and that's why i
asked the question
do you want me to tell you something now
now
this conversation that you've uh
testified to
with regards to the gun
that was in front of dd's stall correct
yes sir
now
isn't lauren cataract's locker
right nearby there
i couldn't tell you sir i have no idea
about that i don't know where her locker
was
um
did you receive any information with
regards to the
possible recording
of private conversations in the
stable area all right don't don't answer
that question
i think it calls for a hearsay answer
doesn't it mr bolenkas
unless she unless she has personal
knowledge herself somehow but
other than that it would be a hearsay
answer
were you concerned about
your private conversations being
recorded
at any time
yes sir
do you have any idea where any
recordings were placed
in the stable area
no sir i do not
now
this conversation with regards to your
uh
your gun
um it was in your vehicle correct yes
sir
and and at the time of that conversation
uh would you agree with me if things
were going crazy at the stable
or on the property
yes
um did michael barriston ever
discuss with you a concern of people
going into your trust i'm going to
object yeah
mr polinkas those are all hearsay
answers they're all objectionable
come on
all right my ruling stands mr balance
that conversation with regards to the
gun
occurred
right in front of bd stall correct yes
sir and
um you indicated that
you were
sleeping
there yes sir
was that a common thing for you to do
when you visited the farm sleeping in
front of my horse's stable yeah no sir
that was not common
i was asked to do that
by michael because of his concern
uh for the horse
on any previous occasion that you have
come to the farm
had you ever slept
in front of your horse's stall no sir
now
with regards to that course
was there an incident
with you and lauren cataract
regarding the feeding of that horse
yes sir
um
during this time
did lauren
i'm not sure what the relevance of this
line of questioning is
all right sorry for that delay ladies
and gentlemen
there are a number of legal issues that
uh come up during testimony as you have
seen that have to be resolved outside of
your presence again i'll try to keep
them at a minimum
but it is important to get that decision
right
all right the objections overruled you
can ask the question mr blancas
dr cox
you indicated that
lord cataract was
coming to this stable after an hour
right yes sir
and
that was against
the rules
yes sir
and
on one of those occasions
when all this stuff is going on
uh did she attempt
to feed your animal yes sir
was that after you told her not to feed
your animal
yes sir it was after she had fed him
and i asked her to please please do not
feed him
and
she did it again
she was feeding him some sugar
lumps of sugar
and were you concerned
in light of everything that was going on
her
feeding
your horse yes sir i was very concerned
and
was she videotaping this
or were you trying to videotape this
yes i did videotape it
and why did you videotape it
because of my concern
for the horse and what was going on with
the horse
did you communicate that to mr barrisson
did i tell him that this had happened
yes yes sir i did when did that happen
when did i tell him yes if you would
call
it would have been the next time that i
saw him what thank you
ladies and gentlemen you did hear some
testimony regarding some
alleged conduct of miss canora
that conduct was admitted only
for a limited purpose
it's not bad character evidence against
miss cataract that's not the purpose of
the testimony the relevance of the
testimony is only whether mr barrissone
learned about it and whether or not it
affected his state of mind in any way
all right that's the only purpose the
court allowed that testimony
in court today it's not meant to be
testimony or evidence about the bad
character of miss counteract all right
very good thank you go ahead mr malinkas
now
he testified on direct with a with
regards to a meeting with an attorney
that you were present at correct yes sir
and
i don't want you to say what was
discussed
but as a result of that
um
we're
strike that
after that meeting with the attorney
did
lauren cataract
come to the stable area
later that day
i did not know how to answer that
question because there were several
meetings with his attorney
so
you'd have to
i don't know how to answer that question
i don't know what day you're talking
about
okay
um
this sport is a dangerous sport correct
yes sir it is
and
um
it's common for people to sign releases
uh in case they're injured okay i know
what day you're talking about now if
that's what you're talking about okay
so
you had a lawyer with a meeting you had
a meeting with the lawyer on that day
correct
and did lauren cataract come to the
stables later that day yes sir she did
and and
was there a discussion with regards to
her signing and release yes sir
and
was rob goodwin there he was
and uh
they basically refused correct yes sir
um
michael garrison was there correct yes
sir i was standing beside him was was
michael barrasson calm
when he was talking to them absolutely
and can you describe
how
robert goodwin was
he was a bit excitable about that
he
you want me to continue to explain it
um he obviously did not like the
situation he made some threatening uh
remarks to michael he also threatened me
robert goodwood threatened you yes sir
what did he say to you
uh he had already made some tell him to
object
to your sake
well well you didn't ask about that
no no no but you didn't your follow-up
question was not about that
right that's why it's objectionable
with all due respect to dr cox her state
of mind is not an issue in this case
mr barris owns this
so if you want to if you want to
rephrase
and ask about
any threat that was made to mr barrison
that may be permissible
understood
dr cox did robert goodwin
threaten michael barisson on that day
yes
what specifically did he tell him
i do not remember the specific words but
it was around
he was not going to
let michael determine what was going on
with him and
his girlfriend's horses
i'm going to show you a
copy of your statement in a subject
she answered the question
i'm going to show her her transcript and
answer it refreshes her recollection as
to the exact words
she didn't say she needed her memory
refreshed
she just answered the question
if i may i'd like to give her the
transcript have her look at her
statement she says she doesn't remember
the exact words
i want to show her statement ask her if
it refreshes her recollection with
regards to the exact words
i'll allow it
with regard to the exact words
what's the exhibit number
uh it appears to be 500-5a
dr cox i'm going to show you
500.5k
do you remember giving a uh
a statement
on august 7th
to the morris county prosecutor's office
yes sir did
can you please turn to
page 31.
okay
lines three
through five
and ask you that refreshes your
recollection with regards to
what the exact words
concerning the threat to michael plus
just just read it to yourself doctor
i have read it sir
does that refresh your recollection
that's exactly it sir
what is exactly it you want me to read
what this says i want you to testify to
what
the exact threat was to michael barason
if that refresh directly
okay you know i don't think she should
read it if she's saying that her
recollection has been refreshed to the
exact words then she can do it for
memory that was the whole point of this
exercise
does that refresh your memory without
without reading it it's it's to
refresh your memory doctor cox that
transcript refreshes my mind now just
testify if you can without reading
specifically what's in your prior
statement okay
he he said
again he said to michael with you doing
the kind of stuff that you're doing
he said so the record is clear judge the
witness is reading from the transcript
right it hasn't been removed
i understand i'll allow in this one
instance
he said i will take you down
now
you were present when the
town
came
and kicked everyone out of the stable
correct yes sir i was
no
were you asked to
go to the farmhouse
at any point
yes sir was and why were you asked to go
to the farmhouse as opposed to michael
well hold on a sec
just yes or no no
but still
we don't know anything about who told
her that or why why she was told it
calls for a hearsay answer
on the day the town came
did you go to the farmhouse
with somebody yes
and did you go inside
yes sir
and were you attacked by cataract storm
yes sir
what's the relevance to that
the dog attacked michael barason
i haven't heard that i haven't wait a
second i haven't first of all i haven't
heard that yet
while it may
have some relevance to the defendant
what is the relevance
to the dog
unfortunately biting dr cox or toxic
attacking the doctor
there's no relevance to that here the
police officer judge testified that the
dog
but mr belinkas you're missing the point
i don't see how that is remotely
relevant
should i'll move on
now
when you gave michael barristone
that gun
isn't it a fact
that both magazines had bullets in them
not to my knowledge that's not a fact
if i can approach again judge i'm going
to show you
again your transcript d 500 5a
which was
a statement you gave
the day of the incident
can you
return to page 23
line 25
can you read that to yourself
and tell me whether it refreshes your
recollection
as to whether or not
there were bullets in the magazines
plural
yes it does it refreshes number one
where they're bullets in the magazines
i'm i'm hesitant with how to answer that
question
if you're asking me if both magazines
were full of bullets
is that what you're asking me you don't
recall one way or the other do you no
sir i don't would you agree with me that
on the seventh you indicated that they
were correct
on the seventh what my answer would be
that i know that one
am i answering this all right okay go
ahead and you looked at me i thought
maybe no no i'm just no
i would tell you if i wanted you to be
quiet okay well i just didn't want to do
anything wrong here so i would i would
tell you that that my recall is that one
magazine was full the other magazine
probably had several bullets in it i
cannot tell you
that both magazines were full of bullets
and that has been my hesitancy to answer
your question i don't know if i've made
it worse or better in what i've said
okay so based on what you say would you
agree with me you're not a hundred
percent sure
as to how many bullets were in each
magazine
that is an absolute correct statement
sir
okay well i'm glad i was part of it
[Laughter]
okay you know
um
you just have a moment
yeah
on the day of the incident
were you asked to uh
stand guard and watch things prior to uh
dcp deif is coming
ask me that question again were you
asked to
come and stand guard or watch over
things
before
cyprus came
who is that
oh that's the child protective service
no sir i was not asked that
nothing further
all right thank you any redirect no
thank you judge
all right dr cox you're all finished
and i may go you may go i'm excused yes
you are thank you please don't discuss
the case with anyone though yes okay
thank you so very much nice seeing you
again
thank you
foreign
wow
so
yes hi man good morning just uh if you
can remain standing oh sorry
i need you to be sworn so place your
left you can put your jacket down on the
chair for a moment
left hand on the bible
please raise your right hand and listen
to my court clerk who will administer
the oath do you swear in the presence of
almighty god that the testimony gives to
this court regarding this matter shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth yes please state your name
your last name for the record vanessa
medrano cortes
m-e-d-r-a-n-o
hyphen
c-o-r-t-e-z thank you
thank you man you may have a seat
please keep your voice up nice and loud
okay in response to questions if you
don't understand the question it's okay
to indicate that you don't understand
i'll have counsel rephrase the question
that's something that you don't
understand okay all right very good
mr sheldon
thank you ron
good morning mr john cortez good morning
can you please uh reintroduce yourself
to the jury and tell them how old you
are yes i am vanessa medrano for tess
and i'm currently 29 years old where do
you work
for the division of child protection and
permanency approximately how long have
you worked for that agency for about six
years and a half can you tell the jury
briefly what the responsibilities of the
division are
so i am an intake role and in the intake
unit where we receive reports of child
abuse or neglect
and were you in that same position in
august of 2019 yes
what are your general day-to-day
responsibilities as a member of the
intake unit
so i receive reports with allegations of
abuse or neglect and my job is to
respond to
the house address that is on the report
to investigate if there is actual
um abuse or neglect
were you in the same or substantially
the same role in august of 2019 yes
how are some of the ways that the
division can be notified or referred of
a case like you just talked about
an individual could call
the scr which is the state center
registry and report concerns or an
incident of abuse or neglect to a child
are there other uh
entities that are mandatory reporting
agencies
or mandatory reporters
um yes it could be
police departments um teachers
medical staff
anybody as a case worker how were you
assigned your cases
we go based on a rotation list of about
15 people and whoever's next receives
the next case
what determines uh the response time for
when you would respond to investigate
so there are two types of referrals one
is the child protective services
referral the other one is
child welfare assessment the child
protective services referral actually
has allegations of abuse or neglect
to be investigated and with the child's
welfare services referral we assess for
services for the family in order to
bring stability or any help they may
need as well
with respect to a child protective
services for abuse or neglect are there
different categories of response time
yes there is a 24-hour response and also
an immediate response
in your experience does the referral
typically include
an alleged perpetrator
on the child protective services
referral yes what is an alleged
perpetrator someone who is being accused
of the
act whether it is abuse or neglect
towards a child when you're assigned a
case can you tell the jury what the
steps you take are to begin your
investigation
yes so i do resp i called a reporter
to find out more information
about the allegations of abuse or
neglect and then i proceed to the home
unannounced
an interview sorry interview everyone
privately
do you review the uh screening summary
yes can you tell the jury what the
screening summary is the screening
summary is a report where
it gives the details of
the incident that happened with concerns
of abuse or neglect
now you indicated that there are two
types of referrals abuse or neglect what
are some examples of abuse
so with the views um some examples could
be emotional abuse sexual abuse physical
abuse
among those and with the uh respect to
neglect what are some examples of
neglect with neglect
it could be substance abuse
inadequate supervision
um
not enough
food in the home
now do you recall being assigned a
referral on tuesday august 6th regarding
the address of 411 west mill road in
washington township yes
do you know why you were assigned that
referral
i was next on rotation and it was a
child protective services referral with
allegations of neglect
and i'll ask you some questions about
the referral uh do you recall who the
alleged perpetrator was
yes mary gorganis
do you recall whether it involved child
abuse or neglect
an objection judge i'm not going to be
able to get into the specifics
all right objections overload with my
limiting instructions
go ahead mr shellhorn
uh
i was asking you some questions about
the general nature of the referral
and i think you were indicating that
that uh referral in involved
complaint of neglect
yes
and was the response time there listed
for 24 hours yes are you aware that the
reporter of that was safe sport
yes
now based on the information that you
learned from
reviewing the referral and the screening
summary what was your response plan
um i went out and announced to the home
and
took a state vehicle with me
and my plan was to interview everyone
privately
did you also know the name from the
referral of michael barrisson
yes he was listed as a household member
do you recall if an individual named
lauren canareck was listed at all in
that report i don't recall
now on august 7 2019 did you arrive to
411 west mill in in the minivan yes and
you recall whether you were by yourself
or with anyone else i was by myself
were you made aware of any safety
concerns no
if you were would that have changed your
response
yes
were you there looking specifically for
michael bearson
no
when you arrived at the address do you
remember approximately or the general
area where you went on the property
i went towards the barn
all the way down the driveway i will
call it
and parked on the left side of the barn
it's in the front
now i'm going to judge if i could have
permission to show three exhibits that
are already in evidence 301 302
and 312.
yes
they may be shown to the witness
up on the screen
approximately what time of day was it
when you arrived to the
it was in the afternoon maybe
1 1 30.
so i recognize uh that s 312 is a
picture in the dark but aside from that
what do you recognize s 312 to me
uh the barn
the main entrance of the barn
and is that the same barn that you
recall going on august 7 2019 yes when
you arrived to the property and you were
in this area did you park in the parking
lot yes do you see the area where you
parked on this picture yes on the left
side by the black car
when you got uh did you get out of your
car
um
no i parked and a male came towards me i
didn't know
it was michael barrison then
but um
i left the band and that's when he
introduced himself
did you tell him where you were yes and
what else did you tell him very vaguely
that we had a ref i had a referral from
child protective services
did you get into any specifics about the
referral no why not
because i discuss the details of the
referral individually and privately
and is that your common practice and
your habit yes
when you told him who you were and where
you were there from uh what did you do
next
um he called miss
garganus she came outside of the door
and
she allowed me to go inside the office
of the barn do you recall
when you did you go in that door that we
see on s312 yes and you recall which
direction you went when you went inside
the door towards the left
and i'm going to show you a picture
that's entered into evidence as s-301
what do you recognize s-301 today
the office
and does that appear to be the same uh
or substantially the same condition that
the office was in when you met
with uh mr danis
mostly yes except the chair of positions
and just so the record is clear are you
aware of whether mr genis had another
last name or went by another last name
at times
i wasn't aware when i arrived
and are you aware now that
she also has the last name of gray
yes
now s 301 is a picture of the office
that you indicated that you met
with
and i'll call her miss gray because
that's how we've been referring to her
so i apologize if that's somewhat
confusing uh that's the office that you
met with miss graham yes
and when you met with her in that office
was anyone else present with you
no
was the door open or closed
the door was closed
and do you recall if you were sitting
standing or something else i was sitting
how about great miss gray was sitting
towards the window
now just without getting into any of the
details now uh did you tell her any more
specific details about why you were
there yes i discussed the details of the
report with her
do you remember approximately how long
you spoke with her
for about 30 minutes
during the course of time that you were
meeting with miss gray in this office
with the door closed did anyone
interrupt you
yes mr barrison came to the office about
three times
what did you tell him uh the first time
that he interrupted you
that i needed to speak with her
privately first
what did you tell him the second time
that he interrupted
i'm sure you're safe
how was it here saying
what she told michael barrison
it's not hearsay
i'll ask you a question again yes um so
my question was what did you tell him
the second time that he interrupted you
he asked me if we were almost done and
and i said
that we weren't done yet a couple more
minutes
uh on the third time that he interrupted
you did he say anything to you and mrs
graham
he said that he needed the office i had
told him that i was almost done with
releases
the person always needs to sign releases
um
so yeah he said he needed the office and
after he told you and ms gray that he
needed the office did you stay there or
leave we moved to the next room
had you ever met mr garrison before that
day no do you recall what his appearance
or demeanor was
he appeared to be
confused
somewhat upset
did you see him running around at all
no i was in the office at all times
when you were in the room or had any
interaction with him did you hear him
yelling
no
do you recall whether there was a safe
inside of that office
yes
and i'm going to show you what's been
marked
and entered into evidence as s302 do you
see the safe in this picture yes can you
tell the jury where it is
on the right side of the picture
of the wall
did you see whether or not anyone went
into that safe
um miss gray
retrieved documents from the safe
to show me
and do you recall who opened the sig
no
directing your attention back to the
third time that the defendant
interrupted you and ms gray
do you recall anything specific about
what he did when he interrupted on that
third occasion
as we were leaving the office he grabbed
her arm and kissed her
he grabbed ms gray's arm and kissed her
yes kissed her on the cheek um as i was
in the middle of both of them
did you see the defendant again
no
were you still at the property of 411
west mill road when the police arrived
yes
do you have any personal or direct
knowledge of what happened elsewhere on
the property that day no
just two more questions ms major anna
cortez
based on what happened was the case
transferred to another caseworker yes
and did that caseworker complete any
follow-up or investigation and prepare
any reports yes
judge no further questions thank you all
right cross-examination
no questions
all right you may step down man thanks
judge i know it's probably a little
early for our morning break but i do
want to check and make sure the next
witness is here and i expect that that
witness will will certainly take us
through the rest of the morning
all right
um there's a little you want to break
now if we could break now then i think
we could typically push through
all right we'll break now 20 minutes
ladies and gentlemen and then um we'll
work through
until lunch with the next witness thank
you
[Music]
so
all right we'll take 20 minutes
yes
you